mais là ça c'est toujours moi qui
n'appelait pas si c'est un mec qui veut
apprendre qu'habitat l'angleterre qui
veut apprendre l'anglais mais pas du
tout
peu importe mais pas dans le ternois
mais j'irai sans doute un chômeur qui va
chômeurs y en a plein qui perd son
chômage et toutes façons c'est un peu
c'est de trouver du boulot maintenant il
faut être bilingue il faut apprendre
l'anglais
c'est impossible nos journalistes voilà
apprenez l'anglais en une semaine quatre
mille euros
donné comme elles m'ont bilingue en une
semaine 7000 euros apprenez sortait
parfaitement l'anglais 8000 clients je
peux pas je peux pas mais c'est
impossible donc sera jamais et plus beau
moment il va faire notre journal y voit
donner totalement bilingue en une
semaine à prenez l'anglais 50 euros dit
[ __ ] c'est une faute de cocu il y va
quand même avec 10 juillet il va il
frappe à la porte du mec toc toc
mais coup la porte il fait excuser moi
je vais pour le l'annoncé dans le
journal qu'il ya une erreur
marchéaux advenait bilingue apprenez
l'anglais parfaitement en une semaine
c'est bien ici mais qui lui fait is it
between
[Rires]
dans un bar effet un whisky souley alors
que ça commence
la porte le whisky le bois a su faire un
deuxième mais avant que ça commence
deuxièmement nom complet papa papa poule
un troisième sous peine 3 points
troisième avant que ça commence 4e avant
que ça commence
cinq six suisses biais sous du du 10e la
main qui fait un dixième un whisky
souple mais qui sert lui ce qu'il aimait
à monsieur va falloir payer
et voilà ça commence bach à mozart et
terrasses de café serveurs qui arrivent
eux
monsieur bac est souvent vrai bain qui
fait les cinq oeuvres de données - débit
ok et vous monsieur mozart bah alors la
côte d'voire cinq heures aux [ __ ] un
baby come back
[Rires]
je te la donne a reçu ce cadeau c'est
johnny moi c'est lui qui me l'a raconté
ça lui est arrivé donc c'est normal
qu'ils arrivent non il va dans un va
dans un supermarché c'est déjà ce que
pendant les vacances l'a décidé dans un
supermarché ce qui est un bon faire les
courses machin on est en vacances il
fait les courses il pousse le cas dit
elle est ici à côté et où il pousse le
caddie pousse le caddie machin est il
pour les trucs et tout et puis il ya les
mecs dans le supermarché qui distribue
les ddd biftons de tombola toi comme ça
je l'aï nommé un dans le caddie et tous
d'ici à le prendre ou depuis continuer
un peu le ramdam autour c'est johnny qui
dans ce supermarché et une en temps au
micro ou de devis minutes et le numéro
gagnant
évidemment les ti s'est lui fait johnny
c'est toi tu as ta le numéro tu fais je
m'en fous je peux y aller mais si si
balsillie va compter un nom donné il y
va elie 20 et le mec déjà bondi de
surpris de voir johnny tu vois combien
un commun gagner alors à temps il a
gagné son toit il en faisait d'abord une
loi non madrid a gagné son poids en
chocolat bon son poids parce que c'est
la promo en noix de coco un chocolat
noix de coco et et 150 euros par jour
150 euros par jour jusqu'à ce qu'il fit
des bounty
là
comme il fallait merci claude merci et
pour être sûr de ne rien rater de nos
latitudes abonnez vous je m'étais un peu
ce bleu